منذ دخل تاريخ تركيا ذات مساء ولا عمودا
من اعمدته فيكاد الاتراك اليوم ينقسمون
بين مؤيدين ومعارضين
فعلاقته الرجل بالديمقراطيه بلاده قديمه
فقد ولد مع بواكير التعدد الحزبي عام
تربى فقيرا في قاسم باشا باسطنبول على يد
والدين محافظين شحدت مظاهر الفقر حواسه
صغيره واستفزته مشاهد الاحتقال العلماني
لذلك الجانب الاسلامي من بلاده وهو
المتدين القادم من مدارس الائمه والخطباء
ثم من اداره الاعمال بعد ذلك خطا خطواته
السياسيه الاولى في تركيا التسعينات
متسلحا بالاحلام والكلمات
[موسيقى]
تركيا الفقيره الحائره في حسم وجهتها
الحضاريه كانت ممزقه الوجدان بين عسكريين
متغربين وشباب حالم بدمقراطيه متصالحه مع
ماضيه العثماني
[تصفيق]
وفي انعطافه منعطافات التاريخ تسلم الرجل
اكبر بلديه في البلاد منتخبا على لوائح
حزب الرفاهي بزعامه نجم الدين اربكان
انهمك الشاب الذي لا يكل من العمل في بناء
عاصمه العثمانيين فحل معضلاتها البنيويه
ولم يترك باب من ابواب التنميه الا قدم
فيه نموذجا فاجا الناخب التركي الذي ادمن
سوء الظن بكثير من سياسيى وما كاد ينهي
ماموريته حتى سيق الى السجن لقراءته
ابياتا راها العلمانيون مسيئه لهويه
الدوله
[موسيقى]
عرف الخطيب البليغ ولا مسجون وحرم حقه
السياسيه خمسه اعوام لكنه ورفاقه اسسوا
حزب العداله والتنميه ليفوزوا فوزا كاسحا
في انتخابات 2002 لم يتسلم رئاسه الوزراء
بسبب الحظر القضائي فانتظرت جماهيره
العطشة للكاريزما حتى جاء ربيع 2003
رجب طيب اردوغان رئيسا لوزرائي تركيا
انتخب رئيسا للوزراء ثلاثا تباعا قفست
خلالها البلاد من دوله فقيره هامشيه يتحكم
فيها العساكر الى دوله صناعيه واكثر
ديمقراطيه تعزز البناء الديمقراطي بكفي يد
الجيش دستوريا وسدد الديون صندوق النقد
الدولي وتحررت تركيا من الوصايه الدوليه
انشغلت البلاد الواثقه من نفسها بالتنقيب
عن الغاز والبترول وانهمكت في بناء ترسانه
عسكريه توجدها مسيرته برقدار كما فتحت على
محيطها باعتباره عمقا استراتيجيا كاسير
الوسطى والقوقاز والبلقان والعالم العربي
الى اللعب على المسرح الدولي بعنفوان جديد
جاذب الغربيين ساحات الربيع العربي وفتح
بلاده للسوريين المطرودين عن منافذ العالم
وبدات متاعبه لكن احدا لم يتوقع هذه
الصوره
افشل الرجل الانقلاب باتصال كما يقول
انصاره وخرج الاتراك الى الساحات يقارعون
الدبابات
وذاكرتهم مشحونه بقصص الانقلابات
والاعدامات هبط اردوغان ومطار اسطنبول بعد
ساعات من مراوغه الطائرات العسكريه
لانقلابيه لتكتمل بذلك صوره الزعامه عند
محبي
المؤسسات ممن وصفهم بالخونه وكمل باستفتاء
دستوري غير به النظام البرلماني الى رئاسي
مما قاد لهذه المشاهد تحت قبه البرلمان
التي كانت قويه يوما لا تنسى ذلك ويفهم
علاقتها النفسيه بالزعامات فيعزف دوما تلك
النغمات
يشتريح قرارات من صميم السياده تغضب اعداء
الماضي كالوجود العسكري في الخارج من
سوريا والعراق الى اذربيجانه والصومال
وليبيا وقطر والبانيا كما قام باعاده
الاذان الى محاريب ايا صوفيا بعد غيابه
العقود فعل ذلك رغم كل بيانات التنديد
الاتيه من الشرق والغرب
[موسيقى]
من الكاريزما والقرب من الناس
والتصالحي مع الهويه طلال البدر علينا
جعلته اول سياسي لم يسمعه الناخب التركي
كلمه لا لاكثر من عقدين لكن الفتوره
الاقتصادي وبروزه طبقه شبابيه لم ترى غير
وجهه وفشله في الاحتفاظ ببعض المقربين منه
جعلته يواجه اكبر تحدياته فقد تركه معظم
القاده الذين شاركوه تاسيس الحلم من عبد
الله غول الى علي بابا جان
يواجهها منذ خرج من حواري اسطنبول الفقيره
ليمد اجنحته السياسيه على كل تركيا تركيا
التي يكاد دارسوها يجمعون على انها قبله
ليست كما